oubliez le rem de l'ouest et ses
faiblesses voici les améliorations selon
la caisse de dépôt pour le futur rem de
l'est une structure environ deux mètres
- large arrondies et posé sur des
piliers de béton qui seront différents
les uns des autres ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui le ca rivalise avec l'inpi
beaupré jeune allemande alors les traits
à fiat ce travail qui a été fait le
comité d'experts avait émis plusieurs
réserves sur l'intégration au quartier
les matériaux ou encore l'alimentation
électrique par caténaire ya de
l'amélioration ya du progrès il ya des
efforts d'ingénierie qui ont été mis de
l'avant qu'on leur connaît mais il reste
encore du travail à faire
voici ce que verrait les passagers en
arrivant au centre ville sur le
boulevard rené lévesque et voici ce
qu'on verrait au sol cdpq infra propose
de retirer quatre voies de circulation
pour faire place au transport actif
montréal veut bien mais réclament les
moyens pour le faire en même temps que
leur m on veut s'assurer d'avoir une
entente qui nous garantit que ça très
beau d'emprunt extrêmement beau et
pléven et agréable très fonctionnel au
sol seuls aménagements qui serait assuré
par la caisse la trémie la jonction
entre l'aérien et le souterrain au
centre-ville qui serait transformé en
place et en belvédère mais le long du
tracé plus à l'est tout le monde n'est
pas convaincu encore beaucoup trop a
racheté un premier arman nous c'est le
tracé aérien vous savez ici le ce que ça
veut dire aussi beau que ce soit serait
craint le bruit qu'on entend ce moment
c'est la circulation routière ça reste
inacceptable et ce projet leur met
définitivement pop préparait avant de le
présenter au bureau d'audiences
publiques sur l'environnement ce
printemps un point du tracé reste en
suspens c'est l'absence de connexion au
terminus de la ligne verte du métro avec
cette nouvelle vision globale cdpq infra
d'y répondre à 80% des questions et les
20% restants pourraient toujours faire
dérailler le projet si mathieu prost
radio canada montréal
avec nous jean marc carbo président chef
de la direction de cdpq infra bonsoir
bonsoir alors et vous avez même amené
des deux vos vidéos nouvelle vidéo ou
envoi de quoi aurait l'air l'on voit ça
c'est on reconnaît que ses chaussures
-elle d'hydro-québec donc ce rené
lévesque et ça c'est là la sortie en
fait on est de l'autre côté parce qu'il
ya un petit bout de tunnel c'est parce
que ça c'est la solution qu'a ramené les
équipes pour on voit on va voir le
projet ça c'est la structure aérienne
qui rentre on voit un train qui rentrent
qui rentrent en souterrain et pour
éviter qu'ils aient une fracture parce
que c'était une inquiétude on a créé
c'est ce lieu on appelle le belvédère
puis tu fais finalement devient un lieu
d'ensemble et de promenades et de
réorganisation puis dans le voit au
dessus en fait je voudrais dire le
projet peut-être pour résumer l'envoi la
promenade il ya trois composantes il y
avait trois composantes vraiment
importante pour pour qu'ils s'intègrent
bien la première c'est les structures
aériennes les coques tel coup de
volaille voiron navigation plus petit
fond elles sont beaucoup plus petites
ces faits neuf mètres et regarder tout
le travail d'intégration
et d'ingénierie d'architecturé et
d'ingénierie il a des centaines de
spécialistes qui ont travaillé à
optimiser l'ensemble du projet à mener
un
résultat comme le disait mon collègue
aprilia les stations ça c'est le
deuxième composante importante sur
chaque territoire il ya 12 à peu près
territoire sur l'ensemble du projet que
ça c'est d'identifier bien au territoire
chaque station locale et les piller les
dépassements préfabriqués wii est monté
ça c'est le plus petit que vous pouvez
faire oui là on peut pas faire plus
petit que ça
c'est vraiment optimisé c'est vraiment
au le plus lisse le plus aérien la plus
que c'est une belle structure de coqs et
les caténaires qui avait frappé quand on
les a vu apparaître parce que vous aviez
un pas totalement destinée à une
certaine pas dans les premièr m les
caténaires électriques le long les
verreault-paul là-dessus mais je parle
on les voit un peu plus tard c'est en
anneau et ça s'intègre dans la structure
a scellé ça s'est su du rem qui sera en
fonction d'abord est ce que sud centre
ville c'est qu'on n'a pas créé oui c'est
ça les caténaires du centre-ville c'est
comme ça oui là on les voit avec les
fils les arts et chats qui a un
espacement de 40 mètres à peu près entre
chaque bon en dessous un des concepts
que vous avez développé c'est que en
dessous puis le rapport qu elle ne le
dit il ya une espèce de grandes
promenades urbaines avec p cyclables et
tout ça est ce que c'est vous qui payez
pour ça non ça fait partie du concept
d'ensemble du projet nous on propose une
vision puis il ya pour moi il ya trois
composantes j'ai donné les deux
premières à voir un objet architectural
qui intègre vraiment bien
l'ensemble permettent de réaliser le
projet mais il paraît que ça va c'est
intégrer il faut qu'il y ait un pas
clean et marron ce qu'on propose c'est
un concept d'ensemble de parts linéaire
et de révision mais vous payez pas la
caisse paye pas pour ça non mais tu vas
payer pour ça mais ça fait partie d'un
projet c'est un projet faut que les
parties prenantes définissent comment on
organise ça mais c'est un projet
c'est clair que c'est un projet qui doit
être gérée par la ville on sens c'est un
parc linéaire c'est une proposition
qu'on fait je vous montrais le plat du
tracé durable de l'ess une critique
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup entendu
parler spécialise par les chroniqueurs
par la rtm par beaucoup c'est que vous
ne connecte et plus avec une robe au
grain ça c'est votre rennes futur n 1
selon voilà avec les stations vous
deviez connectés honoré-beaugrand ici
vous ne le fait plus parce que vous
passez au plus au sud et que donc vous
cannibaliser la ligne verte qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça
avant la pandémie la ligne verte elle
était saturé si vous regardez le réseau
de la rtm annoncé la ligne verte comme
saturé la connexion à berri uqam pour
tous ceux qui utilisent le site m allez
aussi saturé on cannibalise pas on a
cherché une option les demandes te dirai
ce que vous pouvez regarder une autre
option plus au sud a souligné là on a
sécurisé des terrains pour regarder
cette option là ce qu'on offre ses plus
de transports en commun et pas de la
cannibalisation ligne verte il ya une
partie si vous regardez d'ailleurs dans
l'ensemble il ya une dans les études
achalandage qu'on a donné une partie de
l'achalandage c'est des gens qui avant
utiliser la ligne orange parce que ça à
contribuer à désengorger la ligne orange
la ligne orange et la ligne vers elles
sont saturés le problème la question de
base s'était amené du transport en
commun
efficace
de l'est de montréal au centre ville
dans quelqu'un de pointe aux trembles
quelqu'un qui arrive de l'est de
montréal vote selon votre projet va
pouvoir se rendre au centre ville sans
mettre les pieds dans le métro même si
par un bout il sera parallèle à la ligne
verte oui mais mettra 30 minutes
tandis que 6 vient de pointe aux
trembles en bus puis qui monte dans le
métro il va mettre quasiment une heure
les gens ont dit vous aviez besoin que
les gens restent sur votre trench je
peux réussir plutôt que le métro pour
des questions d'argent que plus on reste
de kilomètres votre ligne plus ça vous
fait de l'argent
ce que vous aviez un intérêt économique
de rentabilité
le projet on le regarde pas avec un
intérêt économique on regarde nous on
regarde avec un intérêt pas économique
au sens optimisé l'achalandage
maximiser ou cannibaliser une ligne ou
une autre le problème c'est choisir de
définir le projet le plus économiquement
viable là ce qu'on fait en fait c'est
qu'on transporte plus de gens
on imagine ja a transporté les noms sont
déjà saturés d'eau plus la rtm vous
écrit dans un rapport il n'y a pas assez
de gens pour supporter ça pourquoi les
des joueurs importants de transport en
commun dans la région plaide que n'y a
pas assez de monde que les études
d'achalandage ne sont pas concluants
nous on utilise des
tous les plus grandes compagnies
d'achalandage de des thunes de ce
domaine en un fait 2 et elles sont
sous tout donne des résultats que ce
qu'on donne t on s'est expliqué sur les
études d'achalandage d'ailleurs moi je
vais faire une parenthèse s'ils
voulaient plupart des modèles
d'achalandage fonctionne avec le prix du
lait sens c'est un des paramètres qui
induit ou pas de l'achalandage c1 c'est
un paradigme intéressant deux choses
importantes avant de vous laisser le le
rapport cloyne qui a été déposé le
rapport d'étape le sou voulu souligner
la mer est nous l'avait dit à cette
émission je veux faire partie de la
prise de décision elle vous le dit ou si
c'est incontournable que vous devez
travailler avec la rtm avec la ville de
montréal est ce que vous allez faire une
place plus grande à ces gens là autour
de la vraie table
l'on fait on a déjà on travaille avec
eux fait 140 pour - réunion avec la
ville on en a fait des dizaines avec la
rtm on travaille avec tout le monde ce
qu'il faut maintenant c'est
effectivement que toutes les parties
prenantes qui est un aliment des parties
prenantes autour d'un projet on a amené
je pense qu'il ya un objet architectural
qui est prêt qui est beau dont on est
très fiers de tout le travail qui a été
fait on a démontré on a eu beaucoup que
pour nous et avec toutes les études
c'est le bon système et c'est un système
qui apporte beaucoup de valeur ajoutée
développement économique à montréal
maintenant ça s'intègre il ya une
promenade il ya tout un tas de choses il
faut toutes les parties prenantes
salines pour réaliser ce projet là nous
on propose quelque chose dans ma
justement revenons à l'essentiel vous
dites on propose quelque chose
ce que vous nous proposez ce soir avec
tous les détails que vous avez donnée
depuis deux jours est ce que dans votre
esprit charbo c'est pas mal la version
finale où il ya encore des ajustements
importants qui peuvent être faits
au comment disait dans le rapport
d'expert il ya 80% des points qui sont
adressés là qui étaient déjà dans le
projet d'origine ou qu'on nous avons
adressé il ya toujours des ajustements
qui peut être fait mais majeure non dans
les grandes lignes le projet il est à un
niveau des finitions très élevé est ce
que un moment donné vous allez dire dans
la vie dit rsa pour le projet en tant
que structure
maintenant tu me fais parce que le
défendit est ce qu'il ya des stations
qui vont se dés peuvent se déplacer un
petit peu oui c'est dans le concept est
ce qu'il ya encore beaucoup de travail à
faire sur l'intégration urbaine sur ce
notion parc linéaire de de travail de
détail à l'intérieur de ça et
développement et de communication dans
l'environnement et des changes avec les
gens certainement oui mais le parc
linéaire on a établi au début c'est pas
la caisse qui personne vous dit ça la
ville puis à québec de payer
parce que mes seins parc linéaire madame
cohen a dit ça fonctionne à l'épaule et
deux vont ensemble oui on est d'accord
c'est je pense que
puis je pense que la première fois je
vous ai parlé le long ça c'est ça que
j'ai dit exactement la même chose c'est
important
c'est une opportunité de recréer la
ville et de faire un parking très bien
je vous pose la même question le cerveau
avant de partir à quel moment vous est
réservé et empile on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas changer pendant trois quatre
cinq ans encore ça serait plus rentable
on peut pas reporter d'abord à quel
moment ça serai prêt pour moi
l'autre jour j'ai dit proposez moi la
question dans quelques jours on est
resté c'était pas facile les derniers
mois moi il ya beaucoup de choses que
les vues depuis longtemps sur quel des
équipes travaillent et c'est là on le
présente on vient de présenter un
concept depuis desquels deux trois mois
on entend beaucoup de choses
sur un projet qui a jamais été vues vous
êtes discuter mais revenez nous vite oui
revenez nous parce qu'on va pas passer
de 3 à ankara discuter non ça c'est
clair qu'on peut pas passer deux trois
ans à discuter mais il n'y a pas deux
mais c'est un beau projet auquel on
croit jean marc arbaud on va s'en
reparler merci d'être venu nous voir ce
soir en direct s'est apprécié